the FBI has identified a suspect in the
murder of a federal judges son the
bureau saying Roy Dan Hollander is the
quote primary subject in the attack and
that he is now dead reports say he
committed suicide the man allegedly
opened fire in Judge Esther Salas his
home early Sunday evening killing her 20
year old son and wounding her husband
according to reports the killer was
dressed like a FedEx driver the judge
she was at home at the time in the
basement and was not injured Jessie let
me start with you this is a very
troubling case because investigators say
the man who did the shooting now dead of
suicide wasn't a mobster wasn't a gang
member there's no clear motive all we
know is that he filed a bunch of
lawsuits in federal court he was a
self-described anti-feminist who sued
over ladies night's drinks at bars and
wanted women drafted for the military
what do you make of all this well very
confusing situation I'm just so sorry
for the judge to lose a son like that
and to have her husband in critical
condition it's just it's a heartbreaking
situation attempts like this are rare
though I think since 1949 there's only
been three judges assassinated in the
United States but they really are
sitting ducks when you think about it I
used to go out and ambush judges all the
time and I was able to come into very
close contact with them at their homes
at restaurants at the courthouse you
know obviously they need more protection
from situations like this as you said
this guy was a male rights attorney
allegedly he kind of got interested in
this line of the law because he married
a Russian woman who then swindled him
out of a lot of money and filed kind of
semi frivolous lawsuits against
universities for having Women's Studies
majors or you know nightclubs for ladies
nights and things like that he had a
case as you said in front of the judge
because he didn't think it was
constitutional that only men were
drafted he wanted women to be drafted
too but unfortunately I don't think
we're gonna find
anything more about his motivation since
he offed himself yeah it's not clear
Emily as a lawyer let me ask you about
protection for judges you know what
Jessi's saying is true I mean even here
in Washington Supreme Court judges don't
even have big entourage of securities
they move around what's your experience
with protection for judges right that's
a great question one and I will say that
I've been only impressed by the level of
security including the FPS with federal
court buildings courthouses and
buildings and from my experience as a
federal attorney but I have to point out
I think the takeaway I'd like viewers to
understand is that it's not about
sensationalist crimes and whether judges
are ruling on organized crime or sex
trafficking rings or sort of the more
salacious cases it is often simply that
unhinged unstable person who snaps and
it is unfortunate that no security is
failsafe but most importantly I think
this is why as a nation we need to focus
on mental health and red flags and
warning signs and if you see something
say something
that all of that also comes from mental
health and mental stability because when
you read it out you know looking back it
seems sort of obvious this guy was
totally unhinged but if you take it one
day at a time then you can't see the
pattern you can't identify it and you
can't get that heightened sense of
security so I would just say that again
it's always it's the lone wolf and it's
always a mental health issue
unfortunately that a lot of these
violent acts stem from so Greg just
again picking up on this line of
questioning about protection for judges
her son the judges son is you know a 20
year old he was killed and her and her
husband 63 he was injured apparently now
in pretty good shape or at least we hope
he'll survive but I just wanted to ask
you the the FBI initially said it's the
husband Mark Andrews 63 who was being
frequently threatened apparently he had
done some work for gangs like the Bloods
and the Crips and things like that
yeah I think it goes back to your
original point that like you-you-you
think it would have been something to do
with gangs or something to do with
Epstein because that's the shiny
that's the shiny bauble and it turns out
it's this unhinged crank you know this
is this guy the name sounded familiar
and then I remembered that he sued a
friend of mine Jim Norton maybe 10 years
ago or 15 years ago I when Jim was on
Opie and Anthony and he had interviewed
this guy who was a complete nut bag
about men's rights and the guy decided
to sue Jim because the phone call was
mean and I think the case got thrown out
and he ended up having to pay Jim
Norton's legal fees he was a complete
nut bag to the point about just the one
of the lessons that you learn from these
things and it's very little that you can
learn is that we let our guard down
whenever there's somebody in a uniform
or a clipboard it's just a weird thing
that we just kind of assumed that that
person is there for a reason and you
know I walk around with the clipboard
all the time because I'm always you know
taking notes and people think I just
generally am a contractor you know
working as I'm why I'm you know when I
walk in my neighborhood and it's amazing
how people just don't that you can trick
people with the simplest things in this
case it was a FedEx uniform that's it I
think what you just said so true and
Dagan just quickly Greg mentioned the
Jeffrey Epstein case that was a case
that the judge had been working on she
worked on a case involve a tax evasion
case involving one of the Real
Housewives but apparently none of that
is why the shooting occurred no and
people paid attention to this in part
because the crime was just so horrific
and jarring and blessings to the family
but because she's sitting she was
assigned to it's an ongoing lawsuit
brought by investors in Deutsche Bank
over the banks handling of just Jeffrey
Epstein's finances and alleging that
they hid the activity of high-risk
customers she was appointed to that
ongoing lawsuit or assigned to it just
four days before the shooting and I
think that that again given the very
suspicious circumstance
of Ebstein's death that that paid an
attention to that initially was
justified but it also raises the issue
of why it's so important that we're able
to arm ourselves and protect ourselves
in our own homes under the Constitution